the whole issue with not anonymity is
like a bit is that is a sort of a one
tries to remain anonymous but if you've
been doing this if you've been doing the
job long enough in New York and if the
restaurant tours are out to find you the
rule is that in my experience they
generally will now they'll pretend not
to know that you're there but if they're
looking for you they'll generally find
you in many cases they know what you
look like already they've worked on the
restaurants where you've been in you
know after the second or third visit
somebody will say there's that guy if
it's if it's me I'm you know six foot
six and I way 480 pounds so they will
they'll spot you anyways and in my case
if I try to disguise myself it would be
even more absurd situation so I I don't
although I register under different
names and I have a credit card with a
different name on it and I tried in
various ways not to call attention to
myself but generally if a restaurant is
just opening within the first two two to
three months they're a they're going to
they're going to see the critics of when
they're there be there treating
everybody like a restaurant critic in
New York there that you know the level
of service is is is a sniveling to the
ants degree it's it's it's it's it's
there it's their job it's a service
industry and there are restaurants for
the highest level and they're they're
treating everybody quite well I think
when wear disguises make a difference is
is where critics will go back after the
second or third year and there's a
conceit taking away stars or adding
stars and it we don't do that at New
York so I don't do that but whenever I
go back to a restaurant or when I go out
on my own excuse me and the place has
been up up three or four or five years
and I don't recognize you or they're not
paying attention to you
you notice you notice a difference in
service and it's basically because the
fancy restaurants survived by
cultivating the clients who go there
again and again and if you're not one of
those people and they don't know you
they're going to treat you they'll treat
you well but they're not going to treat
you as well whereas in the first couple
months they're treating everybody really
well